y llegó el momento de hablar de economía
con nuestro periodista Jorge Hurtado
Jorge buenas noches y bienvenido Buenas
noches María Clara bueno se cumplen 25
años del Banco Central europeo y la
conmemoración estuvo con noticias
económicas Cuáles bueno sin duda alguna
antes hablaron principalmente de la
inflación que es uno de los males que
afecta a la economía Europea el banco
nació en 1998 pocos meses antes de la
introducción del euro y desde entonces
el pib Per cápita del eurozona sea más
que duplicado la inflación ha sido en
promedio del dos coma cero cinco por
ciento en el cuarto de siglo de
existencia de ese banco no muy lejos del
objetivo del banco pero los críticos
afirman que este banco tardó demasiado
tiempo en subir los tipos de interés el
año pasado creyendo que la inflación era
temporal los precios del eurozona
tocaron máximos históricos el año pasado
cuando la invasión rusa disparó también
los precios de la energía sumado a los
retrasos de la cadena
el ministro escuchemos que decía la
presidenta del Banco Central
para el bce nuestra prioridad inmediata
y primordial será volver a situar la
inflación en Nuestro objetivo a medio
plazo del 2% en el momento oportuno y
así lo haremos como dije recientemente
ante los cambios geopolíticos las
transformaciones digitales y la amenaza
de un clima cambiante Habrá más retos
por delante que el bce tendrá que
abordar
Jorge ya a propósito de los precios de
la energía hoy habló al respecto el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin bueno el
presidente habló durante una conferencia
de la unión económica euroasiática
liderada por Rusia en Moscú allí dijo
que los precios de la energía se
aproximan a niveles económicamente
justificados y que Rusia seguía
cumpliendo sus compromisos o escuchemos
no quiero volver sobre lo que nuestros
oponentes han estado diciendo
constantemente sobre la crisis
energética en Europa pero quiero
recordar una vez más de quién la culpa
ahora gracias a Dios los precios de la
energía se acercan a precios
económicamente viables pero de quién es
la culpa North Stream 1 fue reventado
North Stream 2 no se abrió la ruta de
gas Llámale Europa a través de Polonia
fue cerrada por Polonia
sírney
ahora vamos con la noticia que ya
habíamos adelantado en nuestros
titulares el presupuesto de Israel que
hoy el gobierno de Benjamín lo aprobó
entre críticas Bueno este presupuesto se
aprobó luego de semanas de conflictos
internos en el gobierno por la
distribución justamente de esas partidas
una de las mayores críticas es por
establecer más financiamiento para
subsidios a los religiosos según los
detectores esto mantendrá a muchos de
ellos sin trabajar y fuera del mercado
laboral el presupuesto contempla asignar
unos 3.500 millones de euros en fondos
que en parte irán a entidades y
programas Ultra ortodoxos la población
secular siente que los impuestos que
pagan van a estos religi que representan
el 13,5% de la población y más del 50%
de hombres de esta comunidad se dedican
al estudio reciben subsidios y no
trabajan tras la población tras la
aprobación del presupuesto del cheque
que es la moneda oficial cayó un 0,8%
frente al Dólar y el índice bursátil de
referencia de Israel el tea 35 También
cayó un 1,2% Hablamos ahora de América
Latina concretamente de Ecuador vimos
que el presidente Guillermo lasso se
pronunció y dio una rendición de cuentas
de su gobierno qué dijo en materia
económica bueno es el segundo decreto
que emite lazo en este periodo
extraordinario que le permite gobernar
básicamente por decreto hablamos de la
ley de atracción y fomento de
inversiones para el desarrollo
productivo que según lazo busque reducir
los costos y producción y generar muchos
más empleados en la normativa menciona
el desarrollo económico en zonas
fronterizas de Colombia y de con
Colombia y Perú y sugiere exonerar
también del impuesto a la renta por diez
años a los inversores y por 15 años a
quienes lo hagan en de la frontera El
decreto plantea la exención de tributos
al comercio exterior Excepto a las tasas
de servicios aduaneros para importación
de insumo bienes de capital y materias
primas destinadas a estas zonas francas
y en Panamá las autoridades del Canal
están imponiendo nuevas medidas por la
sequía bueno la sequía que afecta al
país está obligando a los
portacontenedores a reducir su carga y
también a pagar tarifas más altas para
cruzar a partir de hoy Los buques
deberán reducir su calado y transportar
menos carga estas medidas podrían
provocar retrasos y costos más altos
para las mercancías que pasan por el
canal de Panamá el canal lucha contra la
falta de agua de antes inclusive de la
ampliación en 2016 allí tienen un
protocolo de tasas y restricciones de
peso que se activa justo cuando empeora
la sequía entre febrero y abril de este
año llovió 50% menos de lo habitual
cerca del área del Canal hablamos del
nivel más bajo en dos décadas por las
esclusas del canal de Panamá suelen
pasar el 5% del comercio global un
número impactante y hablando de números
Cuáles son los indicadores de este
miércoles empezamos en Estados Unidos la
bolsa de Nueva York cerró a la baja ya
que las conversaciones entre la casa
blanca y los líderes del Congreso sobre
el aumento del techo de la deuda de
Estados Unidos seguían sin resultados
también por desacuerdos entre los
miembros de la Fed sobre los futuros de
los tipos de interés en ese país en
Europa hubo una nueva oleada de ventas
que hizo que la policía europea
registraran su mayor caída en un día en
dos meses esto debido a los escasos
avances en las negociaciones del techo
de la deuda en Estados Unidos y también
el repunte de la inflación subyacente en
Reino Unido y en América Latina no le
fue tan mal la Bolsa Mexicana de valores
rebotó para romper una racha de tres
sesiones consecutivas cerrando en
negativo bueno Jorge Gracias por las
noticias económicas si usted vuelve con
más en una hora Así es nos vemos pronto
continuamos
[Música]